so on a movie like a child's voice where
do you spend the most money well cast
crew and all the logistics the locations
the food and equipment and insurance and
all that and you know it got it all like
it goes into the personnel it's it's all
the below-the-line and but but not for
us I mean it's it's a labor of love on
that point you know our stuff is is not
to pay ourselves that's just me but but
but all of it goes into the the planning
the implementation and then also what I
try to do is I always look at the budget
every couple of days and start to try to
figure out where I can get donations
where I can get discounts where I can
where I can smartly schedule things
better so that we're not spending double
the money to get the same thing that we
could in one day over here if we if we
plan it better or smartly write it you
know write it in a way that doesn't
require because you just got to look at
what you're trying to say right what are
you trying to say with the scene Medici
scene do we need really need to stretch
it out or can we consolidate it here and
maybe combine some things so it's it's a
team effort between me and Edgar but
mine is always to try to find things
that are reducing costs and overhead
every single time well you had the hotel
and it was that somewhere in like
Riverside or Riverside so be cheaper
than LA I'm sure right and in Riverside
is cheaper to film with permits and
everything and you still have to do all
the paperwork and everything else but
it's not it's not expensive they it's
gone up a little bit in the last couple
of years because they have more filming
out there now but this the county of
Riverside is fantastic those two women
that run it they're fantastic as long as
they're there I think they'll do really
really well
City of Riverside is independent of that
the county of Riverside opens you up to
so many other things they have location
services that they'll help you with we
went to seven or eight different motels
and
for groups and I drove out there and I
lobbied all of them my unit is I like
sorry huh what's that like
oh it's difficult you're gonna meet a
lot of a lot of people that don't care
and and but some people when you talk to
them and just tell them what you're
doing and what it's about and and and
you know the realities of what you're
dealing with I'm dealing with a crew of
eight people I've got you know this many
actors coming in and I I need this kind
of room can you help us out we had help
we would not have been able to make the
film without taking out more money to
and away from something else potentially
where I might have to raise some later
if it wasn't for that manager at that
particular Hotel who gave us a discount
because he was personally invested in
that issue and and and you never know
how things are gonna come but that came
from the relationship from his brother
who knew the person who had endorsed
their previous film and a letter of
writing just so happened that he knew
who he was told these guys yeah whatever
they're doing if they're backed by this
guy you helped him out whatever you can
but it wasn't it was who he was the
owner and the heart that he had for this
issue I mean he came all the way out
from Riverside with his family and his
mother and father to the premiere Wow
and continued to help us afterwards by
taking us into this hotel Association
the Asian American hotels on her session
nobody knows about this but 18,000
numbers one one out of every two hotels
in the country and one of their core
tenants of what they're they're fighting
against is human trafficking in their
chains and they have a program this is
like a top program where all of their
members have to receive training from
the top down down to the housemates
about how to correctly identify the
signs of human trafficking how to
document it and how to get local law
enforcement and local services governing
services involved to get it out of there
and still help the kid because the kids
likes it in danger once that person
knows that they're trapped there they're
trafficking in that and that
you know because they may go somewhere
else but they may do something else too
more crime they come in so these are the
things that like when you connect with
people because of what you're driven by
you speak truthfully to that and I saw a
couple of people that you know no matter
what I said to them you just saw the
lights were out
oh yeah they're just like uh-huh sure
okay yeah we'll talk and you don't hear
anything else and so it's like a day or
two or three that I had to go out there
and talk and and and meet people and
leave cards and follow up but you're
talking about the difference between you
know 107 dollars a night per room versus
less which enables you to do more with
your budget and your crew and maybe add
a day or whatever or you know you you
you don't have to worry about how the
hell am I going to pay for this so it's
it's really valuable to go out there
like as a producer that's what I'd love
to do on the hands-on guy I'd like to
get involved in everything the locations
all of it I I try to some people take
the there's one guy mark Stover laughs I
love the guy he's like beg barter and
steal right and and to me it's like okay
well I'd rather not steal and III don't
want to beg but I I definitely want to
align myself with people that that kind
of like what we do it's like a Grateful
Dead concert you can barter hey my
spaghetti is but the thing is though I'm
sure you could probably see in the ones
that showed you some signs of life like
this person's gonna be easy to work with
whereas others it's all about the dollar
signs yeah you can just feel that
they're not gonna be willing to hey you
know we're gonna run an hour late you
know I mean it was that some of what you
were dealing with engaging their
willingness yeah cuz like if this was
the starting point right this is the
other thing I was kind of mentioned
earlier about you know being fixated on
a person or an idea or a way that you
want to do it you just have to dab and
go that that's not who they are you know
and just and save yourself the trouble
because anything after that you're gonna
have to be asking them for permission to
do all sorts of things and what you want
to do is not to hide it from them but
you want a partner you want somebody
under
gives you like when we wanted to write
an additional scene that pool scene
right right
that night we came up with that while we
were filming and he said yeah go for it
oh yeah we didn't have to like you know
sit there and and negotiate you know
something with them they were just like
yeah you guys do whatever you need to do
they loved us they loved they loved
seeing the film we brought them into the
room we let them you know watch the film
of course they get bored after like 20
minutes because that's how everybody
does all this like this is it yeah but
but making them a part of it and and
showing appreciation you know we put
their name in the credits
it's very special thanks and and you
know we just it's just as a gesture and
so if you put a gesture out there and
someone gives you a gesture back
that's it may not be everything that you
want or envisioned for your movie but
you know work with those people because
they're going to be there for you when
things don't go right you know the way
you planned it and you may need
something else to happen that you didn't
anticipate or something that comes up
and and they I mean they were just so
giving to us it was it was really a
really great thing
you